Google Cloud updates but Cloud next 2023
session guide is live so get excited for
all kinds of networking social and of
course Cloud be sure to register and
take a look at the sessions ahead of the
event we'll be covering all of your key
Cloud topics from data analytics to
scaling and of course all things AI our
functions as a service platform or Faz
reflects our commitment to open source
leveraging Innovations like our
functions Frameworks and build packs so
we're excited to share that we've been
ranked a leader in the Forester wave
functions as a service Q2 2023 report
check out the links below for everything
that we've covered on this week's